uh for this
second part of the morning
yulon glue from the university of
massachusetts amherst which will talk
about statistical sampling with the
birth death dynamics
please young
thank you very much um so thanks first i
want to thank the organizers for
inviting me to um speak in this nice
workshop
um and thanks everyone for coming to
this talk so i will be talking about uh
it's recent work with uh
jan von lu jim nolan uh diane slip jeff
and the hang one
about the status of something with the
bus test dynamics
um so this is based on two works uh one
is with zenfone and jim
and this is the main
focus of this talk and uh the other is
the ongoing work with uh
the yen scripture f and the
uh
and the one and
so the second part lehigh will talk
about in more detail
uh in in next talk
or focus on the earlier question from
gym
so uh if
if anyone has any questions please feel
free to ask
okay so here's an outline of this talk
so i'll give a brief introduction of
sampling problems and also a review of a
few
typical sampling methods
that will focus on the pde perspective
for uh constructing sampling schemes
um
then i'll move to the the idea of
accelerating something using the bus
steps dynamics
and finish with uh with several
conclusions and then
give a few uh future directions
so um what is a sampling problem so um
suppose we are given a target for we
measure pi defined only
three-dimensional occluding space
with a bigger measure level density of
this following form it's uh
proportional to e to the minus v
with the normalization constant is given
by z
we typically assume that the constant z
is unknown uh because it's uh too
expensive to compute a particular one d
is large
or the the the density function is too
complex
so the goal is to construct a sequence
of random samples excise
such that either you know x i's are
ideally distributed according to pi
or in some other cases where you are
only interested in pilgrimage of the
samples
you want to make sure that the empirical
measure is close to the target image
so why why are we she's interested in
sampling problems well
something allowed us to compute any
statistics of the
targeted distribution
because a lot of large numbers tells us
that you can
approximately
expect the value of any absorbable
function
against pi by the impulse average of the
observable evaluated at the samples
or in other words you can approximate pi
by the impulse average of the sample
and also the clt tells us the area
making this approximation typically
decreases as you increase the number of
samples
with the reads
is one one given by one half
and in particular this weight doesn't
depend on the domination of the
distribution
so this means that the monocolous
sampling can actually overcome the cost
of dimensionality
when you use them on the color average
to approximately
the exact average
so that's the um
the
why why we focus on something why
something problem is important in many
many problems
um
so a typical
way or traditional way to construct
something
something
schemes is to use a markov chain
monocolour
and then the basic idea is to build a
angolic markov chain that's denoted by x
t
t can be discrete or continuous
such that the environment distribution
of the markov chain is given by the
target distribution pi okay
and and and you know one of the major
goal of the study of mcmc is to kind of
construct a markov chain so that the
distribution of the uh process is
converted to the uh convenient to the
event distribution as fast as possible
as t goes to infinity
um
there has been many
works on this uh on this topic yeah i
was constructing something methods
uh longitudinal monte carlo uh based on
long-term diffusion either over downtown
underdumped uh schemes hermentone monte
carlo or you know metropolized uh
version of of either either uh either
one of these pdmp processes um for
constructing something like zigzag
uh bouncy particle samplers and also
recently a stem variation of green
descent and many others so i think that
this the previous workshop in this
semester program was many folks on
different kinds of something schemes so
i will not um you know
repeat those those methods
but i will
focus on somehow the online um
mathematics behind those uh the those
methods this is uh the pd kind of
discrimination of the of the of
essentially most of the methods
um
so so so that's what i want to talk
about the pd perspective for something
and data i will somehow uh show that you
can actually tune uh
somehow the pde basically by about the
green flow structure of the of the
the pd's that underlie this dynamics
later on we'll talk about the different
uh ideas for constructing the the metric
and also the green flows so you can
get different uh different um
convergence results for the for the
scheme
for the pd's and also for the sampling
scheme
so um maybe our first recap the uh
perhaps the most uh clinical choice um
uh chronological dynamics for for
sampling is called non-given dynamics
here i'm writing down the overdubbed
version that
it's given by this
stochastic differential equation
um and in practice people usually use
the discoloration
of this
continuous time
process and so yeah so that you can get
uh you know discrete updates of this uh
uh the samples
um
of course those uh discolored version
will usually introduce some bias in the
environment and
one way to crack the bias is to add a
mature metropolis step
on top of this of this uh
analog scheme
to correct the information
um
see so what i want to say about the pde
is about the the density evolution of
this equation
um so as we know that the the
the density evolution
equation of this x t
uh is given by the so-called fog blank
equation
it's a linear elliptic uh so linear
parabolic
pd
um
and there have been many you know ways
to show that
the convergence of the the pd or the
component dynamics by using the for
example functional inequalities or the
coupling arguments uh from probability
to show the exponential components
um
so i want i want to address the uh the
the the equity and flow structure of the
the folk block equation um because i
said later on we're going to choose uh
different metric and or
in some other cases you can choose also
the objective function
to get a different dynamics okay with
the different components uh convoys rate
so uh the the first
result uh
goes back to the the the famous jko
paper in 1998
which says that the forklift equation is
the equivalent flow of the relative
entropy uh respect to the two
weissenstein distance
okay
um
and this actually gives many ways to i
can study the convergence of the uh
foreclosure equation
to the equilibrium for example the
lambda displacement convexity of the
energy functional the relative entropy
was a positive lambda will imply the uh
so-called log sublevel of inequality
um and and this will in the end uh leads
to that like the the convergence of the
density function to equilibrium exactly
with the same
rate
rate is given by the
displacement uh convexity constant or
this logs of the constant
so um this picture this query flow idea
actually
it is very
powerful because it gives a way to view
the something uh from from different
perspective
um
this suggests that something can be
viewed as a minimization problem on the
space of property measures okay
so um
you know the the this this idea goes to
back to this uh you know point out by
this uh payback by uh will be solar and
uh also
by maya and at all
um
so so this um you know motivates a lot
of questions like uh how to actually
design a loss function
on the space of measures
um so the loss function attains the
equilibrium at attendance minimizer
at the uh of the target registration
and how to actually construct the metric
for the grading flow
so that your your dynamics is converging
because it's converging to the
environment
as fast as possible okay so um
and i will talk about um uh recent
dynamics you'll find uh using buster's
idea which somehow um has a different
green infrastructure from this uh uh
it's a jq paper or this uh
versus standard flow um and i will show
that this new dynamics actually has very
surprising
good convergence property
under certain minor conditions
um
so
but before that i want to address um
there's a one important issue about this
long divine diffusion and also many
other dynamics
it's uh it's the slow mixing mixing time
or small slow mixing rate
um
for example in multimodal distributions
the mixing time of longevity and
diffusion can be very long exponentially
long
due to the so-called amount of stability
which means that uh you know your your
dynamics can spend a very long time
around the um
you know each several modes of the of
the distribution or in other words the
local minimal of the
uh the potential function
in the exponent
and then and and then suddenly jumped
between these local minimums okay so um
for example for the
target measure given by the ether minus
v divided by epsilon with a v given by a
double whale potential
the log sub l constant uh lambda
scales like e to the negative c divided
by epsilon with a positive c so when
epsilon is small this number is uh it's
very tiny okay so the reach uh you get
for for long demand dynamics
is very very small
so then the major question is can we
actually construct
other efficient dynamics
for
for overcoming the the multi-modality
issue
with intrinsic better mixing type or
mixing rates than the large
magnification
okay so i have to define what i mean by
better you know
it will be clean in a second
um
and basically
i want to say that can you get a get a
reads which somehow doesn't depend on
the barrier of your of your
potential okay
so that's a that's a goal um
so um
so let's let's uh let's see
um so now i'm going to move to the the
bus that's dynamics
and uh
first
introduce dynamics
using this uh this picture
and uh and then we'll go to the um the
components copy of the office dynamics
so um
so what's what's the idea behind this
verse test
dynamics so let's first think about how
do we actually
uh sample my multi-modal distribution
okay so
our i want to think about this problem
from from a continuous level or from the
pdf level i want to think about how do
we involve the density function to the
target distribution from a given initial
condition okay so let's see my target
target distribution is uh is a double y
distribution um sorry is that as a
distribution with two modes uh which
corresponds to the double well function
um so this is drawn um
this is indicated by this uh this uh red
curve is pi
pi and then i will start my distribution
with a single well um
potential so that's my own zero
which has uh somehow the support around
the first mode or the mode on the left
and let's think about how i'm going to
move this so zero towards pi
okay
so what what large event distribution
does is that uh you know there are two
terms in the in the in the pde right the
the first term is uh the diffusion
laplacian term
uh which somehow smooths out this uh
distance
okay so you you you smooth out the zero
um to some row t right
t bigger than zero
which means that you somehow you know
move the the profile a little bit higher
right as you uh around t bigger and
bigger and also at the same time you
have a drifter or the the
transport parts which somehow drive your
density drive your
uh the the profile to
the high density region right so on the
right side you want to move your
particle somehow a bit higher to to
to this mode on the right okay
so um but if you think about um you know
you want to you want to somehow move the
row zero to pi in the in the in
in a cheaper way or in optimal way this
may not be the uh the optimal choice or
the best choice
um i mean because you can you can
somehow
do the following right so that on the
left you see that your zero initial
density is much higher than this uh uh
target density right so the mass is uh
is much
bigger than this this this pi on the
left so what you can do is uh you can
actually
drag down a little bit of the initial
density towards pi
right on the left hand side
on the right hand side you see that the
initial density is much lower than the
pi the target density so the mass is uh
it's tiny on the right so you should
think about how to increase the mass on
the right directly okay so
at the points where uh the the
the current density is much higher than
the target
you should decrease zero zero the the
the density at that point
and um conversely if if at a point where
the density is much less than the target
measure
you should uh
increase the mass at that point
so um
you know this this is the what we call
the burst status um
both i want to kind of increase the
density at certain points
um and and that's sorry yeah that's
uh that means that i want to decrease uh
the density at certain certain points
where the
uh the current density is much higher
than the pi
so that's a you know a very uh simple
idea and how do i actually
uh construct such dynamics for doing
this well it's actually very
simple uh we can do this by using ode um
although it's it's gonna be an infinite
dimensional od
uh because we want to evolve the
particles at any uh
evolve the density at any location
so
let's consider this uh this following
following ode uh dt rho is equal to
minus alpha t
times rho t where the alpha t
is basically the difference of the log
of my density
um and and the log of the pi
subtract by the average of the same
difference against my current density
okay
so why why this this is doing what i
just said is doing the bus test
mechanism
because uh if you are at the location x
where the root t is much higher than the
pi
so that the uh difference of this uh log
densities
is going to be much larger than the
average so the alpha t is going to be
positive at that point
then you know by this od if alpha is a
positive this dynamics tells me that i
should decrease the function value of
root t
point
okay
and on the other hand uh if i'm at
location x y rho t is much less than pi
so that this uh you know the logarithm
log densities uh its difference of log
density is is less than the average then
alpha is going to be negative
so then
this coefficient will be positive so
this dynamics will uh
increase the mass okay
at x
so this this is a simple
dynamics which
somehow adjust the mass of the roti
according to the relative
ratio or relative
difference of rho t and pi
um
so um i want to mention a few facts
about this this dynamics
the first
you can recognize from this form or this
alpha
that
by the way the alpha is usually called
the bus test rate because this um
adjusts how much you
or the speed of the of the
uh of the evolution of rho t right at
any given point x okay so alpha t is
about step speed and as you can see from
this definition of alpha that uh alpha
will be zero when uh rho t is equal to
pi okay so this means that uh you know
whenever it is equal to pi uh this
dynamics will not move um
uh this means that pi is a stationary
distribution of this uh of this equation
um and and as i said the roti is much
larger than pi then this guy will
decrease and notice much less than pi is
this rho g y increase
um
and also this is the
ode and it's a non-linear
local the um linearity coming from this
uh the log term of rho t and non-local
term because of its average of the log
difference against the current density
so it's not the independent uh ods right
at different locations but those guys
have uh uh low tx actually talk to each
other by this average
so the integral term also guarantees
that the the mass of the roti is
preserved along the evolution
if you take the uh
average the integral protein you look at
the evolution of that this will be
static
this also uh is somehow the the um
the necessary condition for for example
in scheme because you want to say that
in the end you are actually uh getting
your problem imagine right if you start
with the programming measure you end up
with a pro image
also this dynamics is independent of the
unknown normalization constant of a pi
this is very important um because as i
said in practice it's hard to track the
the nomination constant
and the reason why this is the case in
this in this first test equation is
because um you see that if you multiply
the pi by any constant
the log pi appears twice in this
equation
so the the the
they have different signs in front of pi
so if you multiply the pi with some
constant these two constants will cancel
um so in fact this alpha doesn't depend
on the domination constant of pi
so there's one important feature of this
dynamics which to me is actually a bad
feature but data will
kind of want to get rid of this this bad
issue
which is uh the support of lt does not
expand in this dynamics um this is
because this equation is given by ode
if row is zero let's say it's a zero at
a certain point right or the axis within
certain student sets a
the row zero is
[Music]
the od tells me that my rot will stay
zero for any positivity in our set
okay
so so from this um equation
uh the the support i wrote it doesn't
expect okay
so this is bad for us because uh in the
end we want to do something right so if
your target target measure or the
marijuana sample from has a four set for
support on the whole space
um but if you start with your density um
with a compact supported uh initial
condition right
then you know you will never get that
and i would say target image because
your t will stay compact supported um
and the support will not expand
so this is bad news for us um from this
first test
but um
on the other hand
if you get rid of this right you know
this compact support meaning that if you
initialize the density on the whole
space
then
you can actually end up with a with a
with a good good regime which i will
talk next
um
so this is basically what i want to say
first about the local convergence um so
assuming that rho t is a solution of the
versus equation with the energy
condition of zero
and we assume the relation foundation
has a has a bounded derivative entropy
against uh against pi
and also the rule zero is a has a four
support okay
0 is always a
positive for all x
then you can show that the row t is also
positive for for all
x and lt moreover you can actually show
a pointwise convergence and for any
given x and so t
um the the solution of the equation
actually converges to pi
and also um in the pointwise sense and
also in the in the sense of chaotic
projects
okay
this follows from the fact that the the
kl itself is a relative is that the
upload function of the
uh of bus that's dynamics
um
so this is about local convergence which
says that if you initialize a density
you know uh which has a four support and
then you end up with a convergence okay
so what's what's really surprising about
this dynamics is not about the
convergence it's about the convergence
rate okay which i've stayed at the local
convergence rates um i will state the
results
and i will give a comment on this why we
call it local convergence and later in
fact we
improve this results and get a global
confidence as well
so um
so let me state that the theorem so
assuming that rho t is so solve the uh
solve this bossless equation
uh
with initial condition t zero okay let's
say assume that no t zero um the
character variance between t zero and pi
is lesser than one okay
so this this is somehow a uh
uh um coordination condition in the
sense that the uh t 0 is not far from pi
it's bounded by one
and we also assume that
the t
zero has a lower bound compared to the
target measure meaning that the infimum
of the ratio between t 0 and pi is
strictly bounded from below by a small
constant
the constant is defined by e to the
minus m right the m
can be very large so this lower one can
be can be very small okay
um
so what's what do we get for the for
this for the convergence well you can
show that uh for any delta which is a
small constant
they kill between the row t and pi
contracts exponentially after some
after some time t star
with the rate given by two minus the
three uh delta so think about this is
the constant where the constant is
actually close to okay
from from the t from t bigger than t
star and what is the t star t star is uh
you know the t zero the initial initial
time plus the log of the m divided by
delta q
so forget about delta that is some like
arbitrary constant you can you can
ignore that it's a fixed constant
um
the the the really interesting thing is
about the dependence on m or the the the
lower bound um in this in this ratio so
the thing about m can be very large
right m is let's say a hundred and
silent so the lower bound is actually
tiny which somehow allows us to uh you
know initialize the density uh in a
larger class
then the the the delay time or the
waiting time to for us to get the the
exponential convergence
is is only a logarithmic eel
okay
so the the delay time is actually uh not
not horribly long because of the log
dependence in the in exam
um
and also this reads you get um
for the convergence is is is a is a
constant right it doesn't depend on the
the barrier it depends it doesn't depend
on the potential function it only
depends on the
it's a it's a universal constant
in this case it's two
okay so this this this is what i mean by
local convergence what i mean by local
um
is that i have to assume my my initial
condition is within a small neighborhood
of of my uh pi okay our initial
uh the initial condition is a small
inner small number of pi in the sense
that kl is less than one
okay
and also i would assume there's a
quantity quantitative lower bound
quantity quantitative lower bound on
this density ratio
so so this this
this is very nice uh this is a nice
result because uh um you can actually
get a universal rate compared to
compare the launch event on divine in
the in the case where the target density
is a double well um they the rate is
actually expansion small but in this
case um
the rate is is is the same it's a
universal it doesn't depend on the the
potential or the target measure okay
so as i said this is this is the results
we proved in this in this uh first paper
with uh jim fong and jim
um
and uh recently we actually improved
this result by uh removing this uh
initial condition this uh
uh kl is less than one or this uh uh
warm start condition um we only need
this lower bound assumption on the
initial condition uh this is the in the
ongoing work with uh diane and then
behind and like we'll talk about this
result uh in the next talk
okay so that's about the um
the components property of these are
these that was that dynamics
but any questions about the these two
results
okay
so now i'm going to talk about um the
the the effect of the bus test in
accelerating uh the the longevity
dynamics so um
as you see from the the statement of
results we have the similarity
initial density as a lower bound like
compared to the target density
um
in particular so t has to have the full
support on the whole space
um how do we actually get a lower bound
in practice how do we make sure that the
the density is actually only from below
um
or in other words how to actually search
the modes i is this is essentially
saying that you have to
um
initialize the density uh which cover
the four modes right although and any
place on the whole space
so the short answer is you can use
diffusion process
um
because um even if you start with a
complex body distribution if you run the
login diffusion or any diffusion process
for
a positive time amount of time then you
know that the density is going to be
always positive right although it may be
tiny but it's always positive okay so
that's a
that's a one way to get the uh lower
bound assumption in this first test
dynamics of course you can use other
things um but for focus on launch event
diffusion because uh um combined laundry
van with bus stats later onwards have
will have a very nice structure uh in
the on the pd side
so um another question is how large is a
t star right as i said t star is
actually um depending on depends on t 0
and also the log of the log of m
i want to get the estimate for for the
delay time in many situations okay so
let's let's think about a simple case
okay um i'll try to answer this
two questions in a simple example
and then after that we'll
give some numerical examples as well
so let's consider a simple case where my
target measure is supposed on the on the
on the one-dimensional torus from minus
one to one and v is a one divided by
epsilon of the cosine squared pi x okay
uh if you plot the uh the graph of this
uh this pi you will see there are
actually two modes
which corresponds to the two
global minimum of this v
um
and and i will only initialize the
density okay initialize the dynamics
from um
from one mode or the density which is
which is two pi times the the cutoff
function
on on the left
on the left mode
okay so my zero has a compact support
support okay
and and let's think about how do we move
move this uh this compact support
density with a diffusion and then let's
say run the diffusion from stand time
and then
let the boss test take over for the rest
see what's going on uh what can we get
um
for the convergence
and in in this in this case we know that
uh mixing time for large event dynamics
is it's uh very long it's expensive long
um because of this uh small logs of your
constant on this uh
this density
um the mixing time can be improved to um
one log one of epsilon
if we do the forum so if we run the
login dynamics uh for a certain amount
of time let's say we run that not even
from zero to one okay and then we round
the bus stats dynamics from one to to
the rest to
infinity okay
so let's see
uh why why why why we can improve this
log uh this mixing time to log one of
epsilon uh it's because if you first
solve this this laundry line equation
the launch valve or move this part the
profile
according to large event diffusion which
means that you solve the focus problem
equation
then at time one you can get uh some
kind of lower bound for the density
okay
um
this can be proved in many ways um
you can you can get a tiny lower bound
um
it's exponentially small
in absolute okay the lower bound
um but after that once you have this
kind of lower bound
then the bus that's standing the lines
tells me that
you know
after the t star which is a somehow
constant plus a
log of this uh this m exponent in this
case a 1 over epsilon 12
then
you basically get exponential
convergence right e to the minus uh
uh should be that should be a two
something
two over here
um so so so this this kr contracts are
exponential fast uh with a constant rate
after this this weekend time
okay so basically means that you can
actually if you want uh want to make
sure that the kr between the t and pi is
less than less than epsilon let's say
then you can just
lessen delta let's say then you can
wait for this amount of time and then
after that you only take a log of delta
time to reach the delta right
to to make sure that the kl
is less than delta
so compared to this expansion long time
this uh
log one website uh it's it's um
it's much small right the mixing mixing
rate is uh
uh
much better than this uh standard
longevity
fusion okay so um so this is what i what
i said i want to somehow um use a long
divine process to get a lower bond or to
get the
get the full support of the dynamics and
then we'll run the bus that's dynamics
to get a global to get a convergence
so uh this suggests i can combine this
uh there's two uh mechanism longitudinal
diffusion and the bus test and then you
can you can actually
do a simple combination of these two
equations to write down a new pde
we call the bus that's a long event
accelerated launch event dynamics and
this is the somehow the focus equation
corresponding is dynamics
and it turns out this this equation has
a very nice structure
uh in the sense that this is also
gradient flow
of the kerala variance with respect to
the a new metric it's called the wattage
stem facial raw metric
um
it's the distance is defined in a
following way in terms of the kind of
the dynamical formulation
uh where this uh these blue parts
correspond to the watch stand uh
gradient flow or watch the sun distance
whereas the red part corresponds to the
uh the official wall is the visual
distance
um
this watch starfish in raw distance was
first proposed in this uh
i mean these three papers
on the second line
um
and and also this new distance was also
used on this new grading flow was also
used in
uh the the training process training
dynamics for for for for neural networks
okay in this last reference
um
okay so that's about like within flow
structure
um so this is the this is the equation i
will just uh talk about
um this equation is not convenient for
us in practice because uh
the large event part has a nice
particular interpretation meaning that
uh you can view the rho t as a
density function of a stochastic process
but if you add the bus test part and
because of allowing your you know buster
suite
this will no longer have a
particle interpretation okay
so
how do we actually implement this guy in
practice to get a sampling scheme
well
we can do the following so
um
the first step
we're going to smooth out this uh this
equation with the kernel
meaning that when i update or change
this uh bust rate versus rate um
with a colonized weight
um what i mean by this is that the
initial alpha is defined by the
difference of log densities subtract the
average
so now i'm going to write this guy you
know i can write the log log the
difference of log density is a log of
the density ratio
um
then the long local pd corresponds to
the case where you you modify this ratio
by by a convolution you convolve this
density ratio with the kernel
of course when kernel is
close to drag then this dynamic is going
to be close to
the this
original pd
but
the reason we won't modify this this
this equation
by this kernel is because this new pd
can be actually implemented in practice
uh in particular you can actually show
that this solution of this pd can be
approximated by the empirical measure
of a new bus that's introduction
particle systems as n goes to infinity
what is the new interacting particle
system well this consists of two steps
the step one is that
you run the bus that's the the bus
that's sorry you run the large band
dynamics for each particle okay
independently
um
and then you run this to a certain time
a run in time okay so each time it will
somehow carries exponential clock and
when the clock uh runs up
then um
you should uh you should uh swap you
should either cure
duplicated particles according to the
foreign rate okay
and the rate is defined by this uh this
empirical version of the this this
lambda
is lambda x rho t
on the particle level is approximated by
by by this this number
um
so if you iterate these two steps uh for
a small time step and you let
that timestamp go to zero
and and in the end
and also that n goes to infinity then
you can actually show that the role is
close to so the this this dynamics the
empirical major dynamics
uh it's converged to converge into the
solution of the numerical pde
so um i want to show you one simple
simulation result um so you can see the
acceleration effect of this uh
um
versus dynamics
over the launch event diffusion
what you see on the on the in this uh
um movie is that on the top left is uh
you see the the eighth modes okay so
it's actually a gaussian mixture on the
two dimensional uh space
and i initialized the particles on or
near the top mode
um on the top right you see the vanilla
non-divine diffusion process of the our
scheme
and then on the top on the on the bottom
left you see the svgd dynamics which is
deterministic particle scheme
for sampling distribution
and on the right you on the bottom right
you see the bus that's accelerated the
conjuring dynamics
so let's run this um dynamics you see
that um
this last
last movie
you see that uh initially the particles
are around
the top mode um
but then after a few steps
some particles identify more modes
because they are
more particles are duplicated on the
bottom
so once they identify all the modes then
they start
mixing very fast around the modes
okay
so that you get a a good approximation
the input you'll get a better
approximation to the to italian density
while the other samplers for example
holla only a few particles has um have
moved to the bottom um and svg is
deterministic so there's no randomness
um you see that the particles actually
uh going in a different humanistic way
so it's very rigid
and again very few particles identify
onto the board the bottom nodes
okay so
let's go back
okay so let's uh let's summarize um so
um
i discussed a continuous
time bus test dynamics um which can
achieve an asymptotic conveyance rate
which is independent of potential
barrier as i said i stayed at the local
companies without and lee hand next
we'll talk about
the global components which actually
show that this is a global common suite
it's not uh just the exemplary community
um
and in this dynamics um in the
convenience results we do we do not
assume the any function inequalities
like concurrent or log sublevel on the
target distribution
um this was all this was usually assumed
in in knowledge by diffusion or other
diffusion based uh based on something
schemes
in this case we do not need this
functional quality to get convergence
but we do need that the initial
foundation has a full support
so that you can basically mean that you
have identified all the modes and uh
we care about the mixing time um
um once you identify all the modes
so the the and also the bus that's
dynamics can be actually implemented
using an interactive particle system um
there are a few
questions open questions in this
dynamics
the first one is a quantitative error
analysis of this phosphate spanx
which consists of two questions one is a
long time convergence of the
criminalized dynamics and so far i've
been talking about the local local
the the um
localized dynamics where the the
equation is
local but if you have a non-local term
the colonized dynamics
um
it's it's still known how to uh how to
actually prove the convergence of that
and also how to show the mean fuel
estimates or quantitative meaningful
analytic space of the bus test uh
interactive product system to the to the
colonized dynamics
and then finally you know um i think the
big question um
in this green flow uh idea is that how
to actually tune the the white system
metric
to actually get uh
uh the optimal rates how to get the the
the best rate you can you can you can
get
in in our case we would we get this
first test dynamics um somehow this
allows us to get a uniform rate uh
without uh dependence on the potential
barrier um but is any other dynamics
which can do this and
can potentially come out remove the the
um
the lower bound assumption in the
density uh that's the open question
so i think i have to stop thanks a lot
for the attention
thank you yulong
so we have time for uh one question